[Musique]
merci d'être avec nous François Noël
buffet nous accompagner pendant cette
première demi-heure sénateur les
républicains du Rhône président de la
commission des lois on va évidemment
longuement parler de ce débat émigration
qui avait lieu hier au Sénat mais
d'abord un mot sur les deux informations
de des informations qu'on a vu dans le
journal d'abord Adrien catenin ce qui a
donc été condamné hier à 4 mois de
prison avec sursis pour violence envers
son épouse dans un entretien La Voix du
Nord ce matin il dénonce un lynchage
médiatique il exclut de démissionner
est-ce qu'un parlementaire condamné pour
violence conjugale peut rester en poste
il a été condamné par les juridictions
il avait reconnu la fraction la décision
a été prononciée on n'a pas de
commentaires à faire il prend quatre
mois avec sursis il est donc pénalement
condamné sur un plan strictement
juridique ça ne remet pas en cause son
mandat de député il faut que la fraction
soit de la peine soit beaucoup plus
importante après c'est une question
personnelle et c'est une question
d'éthique c'est une question de gestion
interne de la nups avec un de ses
membres je crois qu'il a fait le choix
d'une défense extrêmement offensive qui
est en réalité extrêmement dangereuse
quand on a été condamné pour effet de
cette nature là on essaye plutôt des
discrets de mon point de vue
de parler de lynchage
voilà je pense qu'il ferait mieux de
rester extrêmement discret plutôt que de
réagir de la sorte mais bon il a choisi
une autre stratégie je pense que c'est
la mauvaise ensuite les affaires
internes du de la nuque c'est leurs
affaires internes mais maintenant
la condamnation pénale est passée
c'était le plus important le fait qu'il
reconnaisse et que la condamnation
pénale soit passée la justice est passée
c'est important essentielle l'autre
actualité c'est cette demi-finale France
Maroc et Emmanuel Macron qui se rendra
au Qatar pour soutenir les bleus il a
raison d'y aller
il faut soutenir l'équipe de France
c'est d'abord une demi-finale de Coupe
du Monde c'est la possibilité pour la
France d'obtenir une troisième étoile
donc le président de la République doit
aller se soutenir l'équipe de France le
reste on en reparlera mais il faut en
parler là est-ce qu'il doit aussi passer
un message politique là vous dites c'est
le temps du Mondial avantages politiques
ce sera pour après le message il est
toujours à tous les moments il est
politique quand un président de la
République se déplace donc il vient
soutenir son équipe après il dira ce
qu'il a envie de dire mais c'est d'abord
un événement sportif commençons par cela
privilégions l'événement du moment
il doit pas être un message politique
dès ce soir
il peut dire des choses il peut passer
quelques messages tout de même pas
interdit est-ce que vous craignez des
débordements dans le pays on a vu Gérald
Darmanin qui a déployé dix mille
policiers dont 5000 en région parisienne
c'est un dispositif adapté pour vous
malheureusement on a vu que l'occasion
des matchs précédents l'équipe du Maroc
il y a eu des difficultés il y a eu
une petite partie probablement de
supporters ou pas d'ailleurs et qui ont
profité des circonstances pour faire des
dégâts c'est pas la grande majorité des
supporters marocains qui est un
peuplamis un pays ami donc il faut quand
même dire les choses comme elles sont
espérons simplement que quelque soit le
résultat les gens fassent la fête d'un
côté d'un autre console les autres et
que les choses se passent bien ne
restent bien préparer le dispositif bah
écoutez je l'espère en tous les cas il a
les informations suffisantes je le crois
maintenant des informations nous n'avons
pas d'informations particulières
on va parler de l'immigration puisque le
débat avait lieu hier au Sénat vous avez
été beaucoup cité pendant ce débat
françois-Noël Buffet Elizabeth banquier
donc présenté devant les sénateurs les
grandes lignes de sa politique migratant
avoir les temps forts de cette séance
avec six Jourdain
[Musique]
bonjour Steve bonjour Yann
débat à l'Assemblée la semaine dernière
c'était donc autour du Sénat hier
d'avoir son des mailles migrations
pour connaître les positions des uns et
des autres en prévision de la loi
immigration cette loi qu'on nous annonce
pour le début de l'année prochaine et
comme à l'Assemblée nationale l'isabeth
borne a tenu à présenter la philosophie
du Gouvernement en la matière écoutez-la
une action fondée sur la volonté
d'équilibre et la recherche d'efficacité
d'abord AG sur les causes profondes de
l’immigration en lien avec les pays
d'origine et de transit assuré ensuite
le respect de nos frontières et de notre
droit par des procédures plus rapides et
des mesures d'éloignement mieux
appliquées
le projet loi sera bien présenté et
examiné d'abord au Sénat avant d'aller à
l'Assemblée nationale l'examen à la
Chambre haute devrait débuter au mois de
mars prochain sur le fond du projet la
séance d'hier nous a pas appris grand
chose le gouvernement a rappelé les deux
grandes mesures qui devraient figurer
dans le projet de loi tout d'abord une
accélération des procédures d'expulsion
des étrangers clandestins et puis en
même temps une régularisation des
travailleurs sans papiers dans les
secteurs en tension Oriane et derrière
il y avait évidemment les réactions des
différents groupes politiques comment
ils réagi c'était le plus intéressant
car ce gouvernement n'a qu'une majorité
relative à l'Assemblée il va donc avoir
besoin d'allier au Parlement pour faire
voter ce texte les communistes et les
écologistes du Sénat ne devraient pas
être de cela écouter
nous ne voulons pas de quota et nous
serons vigilants sur cette affaire de
liste des métiers en tension le
gouvernement serait prêt donc à
accueillir des étrangers mais à une
condition leur utilité pour nous il ne
doit pas s'agir de régulariser des
pratiques d'exploitation patronales
comment comprendre qu'un sujet de
société important depuis state considéré
comme réellement prise en charge qu'au
travers d'une vision sécuritaire
peut-être aurions-nous aimé voir et nous
pâcher sur la création d'un véritable
ministère dédié à la politique de
l'immigration de la queue sans la gauche
donc mais sans doute avec les centrist
on rappelle que la majorité sénatoriale
c'est 145 sénateurs LR plus les 57
sénateurs du groupe Union centriste et
ces derniers devraient aller dans le
sens du gouvernement au moment de
l'examen du projet de loi écouter
l'immigration n'a pas vocation à être un
fonds de commerce politique mais être
régulé pour que le contrat social qui
structure la France reste solide
François Noel buffet avec les sandries
les centristes s'en vont pour le vote du
texte et sans vous les républicains
le gouvernement fait état de projets en
réalité de projets extrêmement ciblés il
ne présente pas une politique migratoire
globale prenant en compte l'ensemble des
sujets et qui doivent l'être c'est à
dire que une cohérence globale quelle
stratégie pour la France moi je n'ai pas
entendu hier j'ai entendu des mesures
particulières sur l'immigration
économique sur une forme de
régularisation qui va se mettre en par
une forme des régularisations qui
pourraient se mettre en place sur le
fait de lutter contre l'immigration
clandestine et puis on s'en arrête là il
y a pas de vision globale il n'y a pas
de vision globale c'est ce qu'on a
essayé de faire passer comme message
nous souhaitons nous une vision
cohérente
quelle est l'immigration légale
voulons-nous
quelle priorité dans cette immigration
légale l'immigration économique oui à
quelles conditions parce qu'elle doit
être productive ça doit être une
immigration qualifiée comme le dit le
CDE donc il faut donc organiser cela il
faut aussi s'assurer du respect des
valeurs de la République lorsqu'elle
étranger vient sur le territoire
national
jusqu'en en parle parce que ça concerne
la délivrance des titres de séjour au
gouvernement va poser des conditions
notamment la le passage d'un examen de
langue vous vous dites ok mais il faut
aller encore plus loin c'est ça nous on
dit absolument il y a l'apprentissage de
la langue est essentiel fondamental et
puis en même temps le respect des
valeurs de répliques on a voté il y a
quelques années il y a deux ans un texte
sur les valeurs de la République un
grand renfort de de publicité maintenant
il faut l'appliquer et l'appliquer c'est
demander un étranger qui vient sur le
territoire national de s'engager à
respecter les valeurs de la République
concrètement comment ça pourrait passer
par et donc il peut y avoir un système
de questionnaire un système d'examen de
connaissance de un pays françaises que
ce que sont les valeurs de la République
française de ce qu'elle protège de ce
qu'elle accepte de ce qu'elle n'accepte
pas afin que chacun soit bien là en
conscience la conséquence qu'elle
est-elle c'est que si on respecte pas
cet engagement et bien on ne peut pas
rester sur le territoire national
avec un niveau un peu inférieur à celui
que je propose donc il reste il est
resté il est resté là le principe nous
semble nous semblant être d'accord la
question est maintenant sur la le point
particulier le détail et la main et le
niveau que l'on exige en matière de
langue et en matière de connaissance des
valeurs de la République
aujourd'hui beaucoup trop faible la
formation l'apprentissage de la langue
le nombre d'heures et beaucoup trop
faible il faut que ce soit beaucoup plus
important
les gouvernement c'est essentiel et si
on n'arrive pas à faire cela ça
nécessite de l'argent et des moyens on
ne sert à rien et on perd notre temps
donc ça c'est l'immigration légale et
puis sur l'immigration irrégulière là il
faut simplifier les procédures c'est
essentiel c'est l'objet du rapport que
j'ai commis au mois de mai basé sur un
rapport de
satisfait beaucoup le gouvernement tant
mieux mais qu'il le prenne dans son
intégralité c'est ça l'enjeu parce que
la simplification des procédures est
liée dans le projet des procédures il y
a aussi les moyens donnés au service
dans les préfectures pour mener ce qu'on
appelle les opérations à 360 degrés
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire ça veut dire
qu'on va étudier quand on étranger va se
présenter la préfecture et tu diras
toutes les possibilités
qu'il a pour obtenir un titre de séjour
ou ne pas l'obtenir d'ailleurs et donc
de ce fait là en une seule fois il y
aura plus de discussion possible après
de savoir je picore sur tel modèle titre
de séjour
dans les préfectures c'est pas suffisant
les moyens budgétaires et humains pour
mener cette mission il y a une
expérience qui a été faite à Angers elle
n'est pas tout à fait concluante parce
qu'ils n'ont pas eu tous les moyens pour
le faire mais là il faut aller vraiment
au bout des choses le drame français
c'est qu'on a parfois des bonnes idées
mais quand je donne jamais les moyens
d'aller au bout là c'est absolument
essentiel nous allons donc vérifier cela
et puis il y a l'immigration IR on le
disait la simplification des procédures
elle est fondamentale pour être efficace
il faut avoir des choses à la fois
simples bien évidemment mais qui soit
tenu fermement et exécuter fermement ça
passe par les accords avec les pays
sources donc il faut mettre dans la loi
visa contre les consulaires et il faut
jumeler à cela l'aide au développement
mais qui ne relève pas du Parlement qui
relève directement du gouvernement et
les deux ensemble menés à l'égard des
pays avec des conventions assignées avec
les pays il faut avancer là-dessus comme
il faut avancer sur la réforme de l'aide
médicale d'État ils ne veulent pas et
pourtant il le faut les médicaments
c'est quasiment un milliard d'euros avec
des difficultés un système juridique qui
n'est pas bon il y a des plus de 5000
personnes ont demandé les médicaments
alors qu'ils sont originaires des pays
du G20 tous les pays du G20 ont un
système de soins qui existent qu'on
discute évidemment pour un une maladie
extrêmement grave qui ne trouve pas de
soin dans le pays d'origine il n'y a pas
de difficulté là-dessus mais sur des
pays qui ont le soin et il faut pouvoir
il faut que les gens puissent prendre sa
tête il faut être beaucoup plus
contraignant là-dessus c'est comme pour
l'État et puis il y a aussi les titres
de séjour santé c'est le point que
j’évoquais pardon les médicaments c'est
le panier de soins il y a le titre de
santé je reviens pardon sur le ce que je
viens de vous expliquer et puis le
médical d'État c'est le panier de soins
il faut qu'il soit sur les soins
d'urgence naturellement que la santé
publique faut pas se tromper il faut
soigner les gens mais sur des soins
d'urgence parce que peut pas autrement
c'est aussi un milliard d'euros donc et
ce sont alors je sais bien que on me dit
faut pas dire ça mais ça constitue des
filiales à des migrations incroyables
pas tellement porté par les personnes
mais par les réseaux mafieux qui
profitent du système et en fait qui
profite de la pauvreté des gens ou du
fait de leur ignorance et ces réseaux là
se font un argent fou sur le dos de
personnes qui sont la grande majorité
une partie d'entre elles parfaitement de
bonne volonté mais viennent détourner
toutes les procédures c'est comme pour
l'asile c'est la même chose sur les
métiers en tension
si effectivement de régulariser les
travailleurs sans papiers dans les
métiers en tension c'est une bonne ou
une mauvaise mesure selon vous ça peut
être ça peut être une bonne chose ça
peut être la pire des choses la pire
parce que si on dit on régularise tout
le monde c'est ce qu'on crée là aussi un
appel d'air et tous les tous les gens
vont se dire bon on va aller en France
on va trouver un boulot même si on n'est
pas déclaré et puis de toute façon on
obtiendra un titre de séjour à un moment
ou un autre mais Isabelle
parce que sinon c'est un mauvais signal
envoyé au passage il a fallu quand même
qu'on le dise avant et qu'on le rappelle
avant effectivement il y a une réalité
c'est qu'un certain nombre d'étrangers
en situation irrégulière travail
régulièrement dans les restaurants dans
les métiers en tension dans les aides à
la personne dans les enfin dans tous les
services que l'on connaît de cette
nature et qui sont là depuis longtemps
et que d'ailleurs pour certains d'entre
eux on fait famille il faut dire les
choses telles qu'elles soient et pour
qu'elle il y a pas de difficulté
comportementale si je puis dire il y a
pas de délinquance cela je pense qu'il y
a des critères à déterminer c'est une
bonne mesure et vous pouvez trouver un
accord avec le gouvernement
on peut avancer là-dessus à certaines
conditions et des conditions extrêmement
précises quelles sont les conditions
parce qu'on a l'impression que c'est un
peu la ligne rouge ça pour les répéter
la durée de présence sur le territoire
ça peut être le comportement l'absence
de condamnation pénale par exemple le
respect des règles de la République
enfin tout ce que l'on vient de dire et
l'intégration finalement ce que vous
dites on a l'impression que Gérald
Darmanin dit la même chose donc ça
coince oui parce qu'on est pas très loin
sur le on n'est pas très loin de de
pouvoir être en accord là-dessus la
question c'est comment on le fait et
comment on s'assure que ce qui est fait
et du cas par cas et pas du massif voilà
ça c'est vraiment pour moi la ligne
rouge absolue si ça devait devenir une
régularisation régularisation pardon
massive ce serait non donc si les
critères sont plus serrés plus
individualisés là vous voterez la mesure
et c'est la mesure qui pose problème
c'est à dire si cette lecture
le niveau de de connaissance de la
langue de maîtriser la langue le niveau
de connaissance que l'on exige des
valeurs de la République de ce que la
République française de valeur ça il
faut qu'on aille dans le détail on peut
pas laisser filer les choses comme ça et
les conséquences du non-respect de ceci
leur envoi la capacité aujourd'hui à
négocier avec les pays pour les retours
et c'est passé consulaire il y a une
forme de petite volonté on le sent bien
elle est affichée est-elle réelle
concrètement c'est ce qu'on veut savoir
et puis il y a l'asile sur lequel
l'asile constitue continue d'être une
une procédure il faut protéger les
réfugiés enfin ceux qui le mettent dans
35000 par an les protège il y a pas de
doute là-dessus mais ça constitue pour
les réseaux encore un moyen
d'immigration irrégulière puisque les
sur 130100 000 demandes et 70 000 par an
qui sont rejetés en réalité restent sur
le territoire il ne repartent jamais
donc ça il faut le traiter juste les
métiers en tension ça pourrait concerner
combien de personnes parce que Gérald
Darmanin dit quelques milliers
oui quelques milliers je suis pas
capable de vous dire très précisément
mais ça peut aller très très vite vous
savez c'est la restauration c'est
l'hôtellerie c'est les services à la
personne et il y a beaucoup de métiers
dans le train au public un peu il y a
beaucoup de métiers je vais bientôt
rencontrer le patronage sur ce sujet là
parce que je veux en savoir plus et j'ai
un rendez-vous dès la semaine prochaine
oui c'est la 21e loi immigration en 30
ans ça n'a pas de fin mais c'est bien le
problème c'est que 21 lois en 30 ans
c'est une loi tous les 16 mois à peu
près ça tient pas debout c'est pour ça
que nous voulons
si c'était efficace on aurait pas fait
21 texte donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle on veut je veux un texte global
qui soit cohérent du début jusqu'à la
fin sur tous les sujets pour essayer de
fixer une règle et une stratégie que la
France adopterait et qu'ensuite elle
déclinera la thématique tous les
gouvernements le font depuis
30 ans font des choses finalement assez
partielles
on réagit à des soubresauts à des
situations le Swan Viking par exemple
une situation qui n'aurait jamais dû
exister quand bien même le bateau
accoste sur la au port de Toulon
l'organisation derrière des services de
la préfecture des services de justice la
procédure manifestement ça n'a pas été
anticipé ça n'aurait jamais dû avoir le
dû être anticipé préparé et on aurait dû
avoir ce qu'on appelle dans toutes les
situations une situation une gestion de
crise ça n'a pas été fait résultat des
courses est-ce que notre histoire
nous on a quand même eu 200 personnes le
drogue effectivement à faire mais pas
tout à fait adapté dans les délais qui
sont imposés mais on pouvait compenser
dans l'urgence par un nombre de
magistrats plus nombreux
un dernier mot sur ce texte le fait que
Elisabeth borne confirmière qu'il sera
d'abord examiné au Sénat c'est un bon
signal qui vous envoyez
dans le Sénat et quand elle dit que
parce que c'est la chambre qui travaille
et et qui a des choses à dire qui peut
être besoin aussi des républicains oui
nous sommes pas dupe il y a des raisons
aussi politiques à cela
nous partons sur des bases solides je
crois que les objectifs peuvent nous
rassembler elle va juste c'est une
déclaration d'attention on verra si ça
se traduit dans des accords possibles ou
pas il n'y a pas que le Sénat qui vote
c'est vrai qu'il y a aussi l'Assemblée
nationale dans les circonstances
différentes mais en tous les cas nous on
fera le travail
sur ce texte le choix maintenant est
compliqué c'est soit l'immigration soit
la sécurité sociale soit la retraite
pardon
si on verra mais en tous les cas ce qui
est certain c'est qu'on tiendra notre
ligne et on défendra notre ligne
merci Steve à tout à l'heure de foot et
de la victoire française ce soir
on va aller voir l'actualité chez vous à
Lyon maintenant François Noël buffet on
trouve Alexis André directeur de la
publication de Lyon Mag bonjour Alexis
merci beaucoup
on va parler du conseil de la métropole
de Lyon avec vous qui avez lieu en début
de semaine et vous y revenez dans Lyon
oui tout à fait puisque lundi les élus
ont évoqué le rapport de la mission
d'information du Sénat sur la métropole
de Lyon alors c'est difficile de résumer
ce travail en quelques secondes c'est
difficile également de passionner le
reste de la France pour cette
collectivité qui est unique dans son
histoire et son modèle alors ce que vos
collègues sénateurs ont pu constater
François hollet le buffet c'est
notamment que même dans notre
agglomération et bien les habitants
avaient un vrai problème de sentiment
d'appartenance et de lisibilité de la
métropole ses compétences ses frontières
on a du mal à s'y retrouver donc vous
avez fait une série de recommandations
déplacer les élections métropolitaines
ou encore parachever la scission avec le
département du Rhône alors vous évoquez
surtout dans le rapport le côté
administratif de la chose avec une
nouvelle préfecture une nouvelle maison
départementale des personnes handicapées
mais pour moi par exemple l'habitant de
la métropole qui aux yeux de la poste de
l'administration habite en réalité
toujours dans le 69 est-ce que c'est pas
avec moi qu'il faut commencer pour que
je comprenne bien je ne suis plus un
rhodanien depuis déjà quelques années si
si vous êtes toujours à rosania
rassurez-vous bonjour d'abord vous êtes
toujours en rondanien parce que le
département du Rhône est composé de deux
collectivités il est composé du nouveau
rôle et de la métropole de Lyon mais le
département du Rhône administrativement
reste unique donc vous êtes je suis nous
sommes des Rhodaniens pas de difficultés
et on soutient l'Olympique Lyonnais bon
mais c'est important dans ce rapport
quel est-il c'est que la métropole de
Lyon est extrêmement jeune
elle a finalement elle est la loi date
de 2015 mais elle a vécu entre 2015 et
2020 encore sous la forme qui était la
communauté urbaine de Lyon c'est à dire
d'un EPCI mais que c'est l'élection au
suffrage universel direct de 2020 qui
lui a donné sa réalité donc nous avons
que finalement deux ans bientôt trois
ans d'expérience pas plus et il est vrai
que la conjonction des élections
municipales et des élections
métropolitaines n'a pas permis en tout
cas pour cette première fois à ce que
l'ensemble des habitants de la métropole
mesure à quel point l'élection
métropolitaine est aujourd'hui
importante elle est importante parce que
la métropole c'est une collectivité que
l'on appelle qui a pris les compétences
du département du Rhône et qui
finalement est une collectivité qui se
rapproche plus aujourd'hui en théorie
d'une forme départementale que d'un EPCI
elle a des compétences extrêmement
larges et avec des moyens extrêmement
importants là encore vu lundi à
l'occasion du débat d'orientation
budgétaire donc qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire il faut que la légitimité
issue du suffrage universel direct à la
métropole soit parfaitement ancré dans
le territoire et que les grands lyonnais
est parfaitement conscience des enjeux
de la métropole donc ce que l'on dit
dans le rapport plusieurs propositions
c'est qu'il faut que cette légitimité
elle soit renforcée et que les gens qui
vont voter aux élections pour les
élections métropolitaines et
parfaitement conscience de ce pourquoi
et de ce pour qui il vote donc l'ancrage
territorial est nécessaire et en même
temps la lisibilité de l'élection
métropolitaine doit être le plus parfait
possible parce que c'est absolument
essentiel et alors nous sommes dans un
paradoxe comme toujours à Lyon c'est le
fait que nous avons deux légitimités qui
actuellement s'opposent face s'oppose ou
se frotte si je filme permet de cette
expression entre les mères et lui aussi
fera universel direct et la métropole et
le suffrage universel direct or la
métropole certes à des moyens
extrêmement importants des enjeux
extrêmement forts mais en son sein les
mers aussi donc il faut trouver le moyen
qui se parle et il se parlait peu depuis
le début de l'année 2020 on constaté des
réactions assez fortes de 44 mères qui
trouvaient que il n'était pas
suffisamment écouté respecté on peut
l'entendre cela dit on a proposé dans le
rapport de renforcer deux choses la
conférence métropolitaine des mers pour
être beaucoup plus
contraignant à l'égard du conseil de
métropole sans être au-dessus du conseil
de métropole naturellement et puis le
conférence territoriale des mers qui
correspond à une forme de
déconcentration des services d'une
meilleure écoute des maires des
territoires et donc d'une capacité pour
eux à pouvoir faire des choses je crois
que c'est absolument essentiel ce couple
là qui est un couple j'allais dire un
jeune
doit apprendre à vivre ensemble ça
nécessite des efforts des deux côtés je
l'ai vécu moi en étant élu pendant 30
ans à Oullins maire pendant 20 ans et
j'ai vécu la métropole j'en ai été
membre de son exécutif à une époque je
vois bien l'importance que ça de
d'allier les deux forces si les gens se
séparent se disputent ne s'entendent pas
ce sera un échec au bout du compte et ce
sera un échec pour les élus c'est une
chose mais ce sera aussi un échec pour
les habitants ce qu'il ne faut pas
naturellement
Alexis on va dire un mot de la météo
puisque à Paris on a vu ce matin les
premiers les premières neiges François
de buffet mais alors à Lyon il a
beaucoup neigé ces dernières heures
comme à chaque fois qu'il neige deux ou
trois centimètres chez nous dans toute
l'agglomération est paralysée chez nos
voisins à Grenoble c'était pareil alors
pourtant Météo France avait prévenu hein
la veille mais la métropole de Lyon a
choisi de se concentrer sur les très
grands axes quelques trottoirs et pistes
cyclables le président écologiste a même
indiqué que ça allait à outrance et bien
ce n'était pas très écologiste vous avez
été maire vous François Noël buffet de
Oullins qui a un relief particulier qui
est donc très touché quand il y a des
problèmes liés à la neige est-ce que
vous comprenez que que pour diverses
raisons écologistes d'abord mais aussi
et surtout financière et bien on fasse
l'impasse sur un dispositif de viabilité
hivernale performant en France parce que
et bien les grandes villes sont touchées
une à deux fois par an grand maximum
bien sûr que non enfin c'est
inadmissible quand on a 1401400
000 personnes qui habitent sur votre
territoire on se débrouille pour qu'en
cas d'intempéries le système fonctionne
à Oullins quand j'étais mère bon il y
avait deux quartiers qui étaient
compliqués à distribuer ce qu'il y avait
des collines et les bus montaient pas
tout de suite mais il mentait pas dans
les premières heures mais une fois que
le travail était fait ça augmente ça
marchait tout de suite il y avait ce
qu'on appelait le principe il fallait
revenir au noir sur les grands axes le
principaux et les services de la
métropole travailler la nuit travailler
le jour et on anticipait les choses
alors il est arrivé parfois que ce soit
compliqué parce que la neige tombait à
5h du matin et que c'était compliqué
mais là en l'occurrence on était prévenu
on savait les services de la métropole
sont parfaitement équipés et on rend pas
service à la population donc c'est pas
acceptable sincèrement c'est pas
acceptable c'est jamais parfait parce
que un problème climatique c'est un
problème climatique par nature pas
forcément maîtrisable mais à tout le
moins on doit faire le maximum pour
rendre la vie des habitants
possible allez prendre le métro aller
prendre le bus aller à son travail aller
à l'école enfin quand même malgré tout
on sait que dans cette métropole il y a
des endroits qui sont un peu plus
compliqués mais ça en s'organise il y a
un problème de gestion de cet événement
et d'anticipation en plus bien sûr pas
acceptable
merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec nous la
Une de Lyon max c'est la Lyonnaise de
l'année marie-charlotte-garin député
peuple c'est à la Une de Lyon Mag merci
Alexandrie merci beaucoup François nel
buffet d'avoir été notre invité on vous
souhaite de belles fêtes et on vous
trouvera évidemment à la rentrée merci
d'avoir été avec nous dans 20 minutes
dans le club des territoires on parlera
du très attendu France - Maroc qui fait
déjà la Une de beaucoup de vos
quotidiens régionaux ce matin pour
préparer d'éventuelles débordements
Gérald Darmanin a annoncé un
renforcement du dispositif policier on
verra tout ça mais d'abord on a créé
notre prochaine invité